[Music]
two years ago musician mckinley chadwick
started his career as a sound engineer
now after a year of pandemic he's
struggling and
unsure how he will cope if the 20 pound
a week universal credit lifeline
thrown last spring is withdrawn at the
end of march
got no money i've got like 130 quid in
the bank
it affects people people like me
people like my friends and family you
know my mom's disabled she's on
universal credit
if they cut that that's going to be a
big chunk of our food shopping that
we're not going to be able to afford
the labor leader highlighting what
losing a thousand pounds a year will
mean for many of the six million people
who were helped by the universal credit
boost we're still in the middle of a
pandemic and the government wants to get
rid of that
uplift which is vital to those families
it's the wrong thing
to do i think many tory mps in their
heart of heart
know it's the wrong thing to do he
succeeded in goading some of them to
speak out today
now's not the time to consider any
reduction in the uplift in universal
credit
this uplift was brought in to help
people to the extreme challenges of the
pandemic
and those challenges haven't passed the
uplift is so important right now and
it's why
i believe it needs to be extended for
the further 12 months
the ice to the right 278 the nose to the
left
nil the government managed to stop any
rebel tory mps voting with labour
but that doesn't mean the problem has
gone away fantastic
visiting a vaccine centre in oxford
boris johnson makes clear
no decisions have been taken what we've
said is that we'll put our arms around
the whole of the country
throughout the pandemic the countries
we've already done uh
i think 280 billion pounds worth of of
support
and we'll keep all measures obviously
under under constant review
the fact that boris johnson hasn't
automatically
sided with his chancellor is striking
rishi sunak
wants everybody to be braced for the end
of emergency support that got us through
the pandemic within months
but boris johnson can spy around with
his back benches he doesn't want to have
life is about to get more difficult for
the treasury
not least because furlough ends at the
end of april
meaning that just as a lot of people
have got vaccines
more people are going to end up on
unemployment and hence
on universal credit it's just the little
things
those like mike who lost his job in
hospitality moved back in with his
mother
and is still struggling to cope yes you
know you can live within your means
you know it's a great little phrase but
when you're already living well within
your means and
and still there's not enough money for
the month
i i don't know what to do rishi sunak is
going round whitehall telling people
that whatever he pays for now has to be
paid
back later but when will boris johnson
let him do that
sam coates sky news